bonjour je suis Thierry sénateur et moi
je m'appelle Antoine je suis en 6e je
suis un peu ému car c'est la toute
première fois de ma vie que je vais
entrer au Palais du Luxembourg tiens il
est bientôt 14h je vais t'emmener dans
l'hémicycle pour vivre l'un des temps
forts de notre vie de sénateur la séance
publique
tu vois tout le monde commence à arriver
nous sommes 348 sénateurs et sénatrices
avant d'être élu pour 6 ans nous avons
tous exercer un métier parmi nous il y a
des agriculteurs des médecins des
professeurs des ingénieurs des avocats
cet après-midi nous allons discuter
d'une loi sur le climat on ne sera pas
toujours d'accord mais c'est le jeu
la séance est ouverte la République
française comme tu le sais c'est une
démocratie dans notre pays il y a deux
assemblées le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale elle forme le Parlement notre
mission principale à nous sénateurs et
députés c'est d'examiner les lois à fond
d'y apporter des changements que nous
trouvons nécessaires on appelle ça les
amendements et de les voter et les
sénateurs peuvent-ils aussi proposer une
loi oui bien sûr comme les députés
d'ailleurs on parle de proposition de
loi quand c'est un parlementaire qui a
rédigé le texte et de projet de loi
lorsque c'est le gouvernement qui l'a
écrit pour ma part je déposerai une
proposition de loi cet automne ce sera
sur l'école un sujet que je connais bien
puisque auparavant j'étais instituteur
et à part écrire et voter des lois vous
faites quoi d'autre
avec l'Assemblée nationale nous
contrôlons l'action du gouvernement en
interrogeant les ministres et les
administrations et surtout en nous
déplaçant sur le terrain et en
organisant des auditions
le président de nous avoir invité à
cette audition lorsqu'un sujet demande
un travail d'études approfondie nous
créons ce qu'on appelle des missions
d'information ou des commissions
d'enquête un groupe de sénateurs est
alors chargé pendant plusieurs mois de
récolter le plus d'informations
possibles sur le sujet nous traversons
la France pour rencontrer des experts
des professionnels des élus locaux et
même parfois des enfants ah ça veut dire
que les sénateurs ne sont pas toujours
au Sénat non nous allons souvent dans
notre circonscription le département où
nous sommes élus là nous rencontrons les
habitants les élus locaux qui nous
parlent de leurs difficultés il y
aura-t-il suffisamment de car scolaires
à la rentrée comment créer de nouveaux
emplois pour les jeunes ou au secours il
n'y a plus de boulangerie dans le
village c'est important pour nous de
discuter avec les mères par exemple nous
sommes leur représentants parce que
contrairement aux députés et aux
présidents de la République nous ne
sommes pas directement élus par les
Français mais par 162 000 grands
électeurs ce sont des élus municipaux
département et régionaux souvent nous
les connaissons bien parce que beaucoup
de sénateurs ont eux-mêmes été élus
locaux avant leur mandat parlementaire
c'est notre rôle de représenter les
communes les départements et les régions
ce qu'on appelle les collectivités
territoriales le temps qu'on passe dans
nos circonscriptions nous permet de
mieux cerner les problèmes et de
connaître les souhaits des Français de
retour à Paris au Sénat nous profitons
de cette expérience pour améliorer les
lois et demander des explications au
ministre
quel est votre endroit préféré au Sénat
ah c'est la bibliothèque elle compte
imagine 450 000 livres dont certains
sont très rares en plus elle est décorée
de magnifiques fresques dont
quelques-unes du célèbre peintre Eugène
Delacroix réalisé entre 1841 et 1846
bien sûr tu pourras essayer de devenir
sénateur un jour mais il va quand même
falloir que tu attendes un petit peu car
il faut avoir 24 ans pour se présenter
sache que le plus jeune sénateur a été
élu à seulement 26 ans
j'espère que cette visite t'a plu et que
maintenant tu connais par cœur le Sénat
[Musique]